con la copertina come i vecchi perdere
questo nuovissimo video sono tra i denti
sono tornati dopo quasi un anno credo
ormai ne faccio uno all'anno ricevere o
è uscito il battle royale des adesso tu
mi spieghi com'è possibile che ci sia il
batter royale di geo restano lennon e
pontone mai esistita sta cosa ragazzi
qui allora viste come funziona perché mi
sono informata molto carina allora è
molto veloce tra l'altro lui ti butta
insieme a tutte queste belle persone in
un punto a caso del mondo avevo chiesto
al normale
e tu devi indovinare prima degli altri
cia bandiera questo la bandiera
famosissima del kenya
non lo so perché mia ragazza in africa
comunale con ostuni così arabi arabia
non c'è veneri tra eritrea non eri 3 a
nessuno dati non era sudan faccio chi
abbia capito che non sono proprio il
tocco a questo gioco però vabbè comunque
ti metti non posso a caso nel mondo e
tutti dibattere questi qua c'e proprio
impossibile perché la gente bravissima
il tratto c'era la bandiera se non ho
indovinato con la bandiera comme faccio
senza ragazzi questo è chiaramente
l'austria e perché non dovrebbe esserlo
3,5 tonnellate che figo ma se è forse
sia b l'italia può essere vediamo i
campanelli no
30 hingst bring può essere qualsiasi
cosa regalo madonna regga bene la gente
come fa ad indovinare subito non è
possibile ma non stanno indovinando
perché qua c'è scritto questi sono gli
stati che stanno provando a indovinare
lega un macello aiuto hanno indovinato
in quattro per adesso e mi pare che qui
c'è una bici signora mi dice dove siamo
perché non si capisce su man ga butka
che ieri ha lega ungheria ungheria
ungheria veloce che saprà uscirebbe
dolce perfetto
la giovane usa allora ragazzi quest'anno
propria si può usare google si può usare
come perché loro lo usano solo per
quelli normali non lo uso non gioca in
sé ma loro lo usano quindi l'uso anche
in futuro però è difficile lo stesso
david america dove cacchio è stati uniti
porca vacca
capite perché devono essere più veloce
degli altri le casse non schiaccio
veloce come gli altri vengono vengo
clockato fuori porca vacca da ragazzi
difficili da gente fortissima per gioco
non sono ne sia possibile va bene allora
fa niente andiamo avanti madonnari galan
è veramente difficilissimo cioè se posso
permettermi veramente di casi insieme a
bergamo dove come faccio ma come si può
trovare sta roba
l'importante è non arrivare ultimo è
solo quello e casino perche poi
ovviamente c'è il tempo non ragazzi
impossibile io come lo vendo vi non si
può fare
non si può veniamo crociati fuori tutti
qua
cioè non c'è invece una strada chi non
sa chi sono ci sono due vecchi in bici
ma come faccio a ritrovi la sta roba
los angeles a vega di no che mi sembra
non sono stati uniti ma come los angeles
ma dove kaki no scusami 12 ma c'era
scritto los angeles ma dov è ma va a
cagare
devo arrivare infine almeno in finale e
difficili sidoti giuro secondo me non si
può fare sta però proviamoci è veramente
difficile
mamma mi ha regalato tibet sicuramente
gente di ci gioca c'è pazzesca sta roba
ma da che bella casa cacchio questa
bellissima
detta in campagna noi fossimo noi italia
google aspetta naz
siamo entrati giovani ma povero keaton
arce non è non non è germania e
dall'austria
ecco qua tutto qui cameron è bellissimo
ma in italia che azzecco subito la per
carità però è avvenuta cartello che
questo cartello bosco font madonna che
posto è macchierà una landa gigantesca
non c'è una macchina ci sono le palma
cos'è sto posto nome raga aiuto dove sia
vi prego thailandia thailandia da anni
però c'è però dove cazzo è la thailandia
e 4 no non la thailandia e cup come
faccio no bere caffè in india ningen in
gaming in india
mamma mia il primo primo pinuccio primo
pinuccio organo ragazzi due rate due
volte primo cioè non una parola
incredibile lara gut e come si cagano un
ragazzo a buttano fuori tipi ho vinto
abbiamo vinto in 2 finale
la finale attenzione attenzione essere
indovina sono così finale incredibile
mamma mia si sale fino alle 2
noi ci facciamo western union minchia
turchia subito più chi ha subito subito
turchia subito turchia turchia dove
cazzo alla turchia turchia non so la via
non la trovo e la turchia si vede lì
eccola no tunisia sono questo
sono un [ __ ]
ma porca di una vacca mamma mi avevo
vinto regala tanto dovevo lo carla per
forza perché l'altro aveva bloccato dai
minchia regate pirla che pirla finale
fino a ragazzine anche in forte è questa
qua e torino porta susa e questa bomba
donna che cacchio chicago norma idea
beve stati uniti collocata ma non vocata
non è stato finalmente l'italia questa
classica macchina italiana
no non lo so ma dove kaki hai
parcheggiato zio ma è l'italia perché ci
sono parcheggi così apple yahoo
non sai che non noi lamino non è
l'italia piazza 3 calcio siamo una clio
potrebbe però di un'europa sicuro non
posso mettere europa ma dai ma dai no
ragano noi giudizio potrebbe essere
l'italia tranquillamente ma non ne sono
sicuro dove cacchio son finito ma come
ha fatto google arrivare lì perché
l'italia non all'italia mannaggia il
cacchio ma dove va beh ma ho capi sono
finite in un cunicolo ma come faccio a
trovarla almeno un approccio che noi
siamo tutti bloccati fuori chi la zecca
pinto praticamente le idee leve port
francia potrebbe essere
[Musica]
le devo idratarli perché sto gioco ti
porta proprio gli alle energie cerebrali
comunque la francia una gara difficile
va bene italiano tutta italia allora e
mamma mia che cose strane quella russia
inghilterra
non lo so zurich germania king ha posto
il terzo blues dalla germania la gara
dai clinica germania azzeccato subito
vinto ciao proprio lui proprio lui
proprio lui va bene allora abbiamo
questo è un cespuglio proprio italiano
si vede sarebbe finissimo andare alla
cieca vedrete beckham no vabbè non è mai
italia però va bene salvi cnn dei già
ave lascia la slovenia la slovenia la
slovenia la slovenia slovenia la
slovenia il classico salvi cm è già
comunque hanno indovinato quasi tutti
sarà molto difficile
lui l'ha arabia lo vedo subito a rabbia
arak salta le palme qua o forse egitto
egitto prova locare detto o locato
egitto non era egitto però siamo lì e
l'inter non buttarmi tunisia israele con
figure giochi il gioco più difficile
visto viene però sono arrivato in finale
due volte regala due volte non è male ci
riproviamo perché bellissimo secondo me
ragazzuoli spero che vi sia piaciuto
questa ragione s imbatte royale ragazzi
include visto che oggi fa lei sapere se
mi piace noi tanti episodi iscritte dal
canale sono migliaia e noi come sempre
ci vediamo
[Musica]